Jefferson at Madison and William O
Douglas and everybody took a stand for
human liberty would be turning in their
graves hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason
TV and today we're talking with Judge
Andrew Napolitano he's a Fox News legal
analyst and he is the author of many
books most recently the brand-new book
with a foreword by Rand Paul
it's called suicide pact the radical
expansion of presidential powers and the
assault on civil liberties judge thanks
for talking about it's a pleasure to be
here Nick
alright let's get right to it the the
radical expansion of presidential powers
and the assault on civil liberties this
is a history going back to the early
Republican period you say that the
driving force here is war real and
imagined talk a little bit about that
yes well the first half of this book is
a history of presidential lawmaking and
law-breaking starting with George
Washington and going to Bill Clinton
second half of the book focuses in in
great detail on the executive orders and
the unlawful actions of george w bush
and barack obama so a lot of the
historical stuff is familiar to readers
and some is not familiar it's
interesting I find that if readers went
to a public high school they don't know
a lot of a history in here if there were
homeschooled or if they went to a
private school or a religious school
they know a lot of this is what explains
I'm the public schools have a built-in
need to reinforce the primacy of
government as the benefactor of our
rights so talk about I mean just very
quickly and I want to spend most of our
time talking about Obama and George Bush
right w bush but George Washington what
was the original sin here
well George Washington actually engaged
in a lot of bizarre activity involving
his his slaves unlike much of which is
owned remember the first capital of the
country was Philadelphia Philadelphia
and the Pennsylvania legislature
required manumission of slaves after six
months so George and Martha just ran the
slaves up from Mount Vernon and at the
end of the six months just send them
back so they had a continual train of
slaves unfortunately when they tried to
escape
cut their toes off and unfortunately
when he and his children needed teeth he
pulled their teeth out one of the more
egregious things about George Washington
was his chopping the heads off of
soldiers in the Continental Army so he
wasn't yet the president there wasn't
yet a country even though they were
volunteers John Adams we see prosecuting
people for speech under the Alien and
Sedition Acts Abraham Lincoln's excesses
are well known but but among the more
egregious is the suspension of writ of
habeas corpus of the writ of habeas
corpus and arresting 3,000 newspaper
publishers in the north for being
critical of him in their editorials
Woodrow Wilson had FBI agents arrest
people for singing German songs in
public and for reciting the Declaration
of Independence outside of draft boards
FDR had FDA FBI agents confiscate gold
he forgot that only the Congress could
make the ownership of gold on unlawful
the the theme is not only war because
war is the health of the state and war
people were willingly paying more taxes
they will willingly stand in line for
things that if the government didn't
regulate them there'd be plenty of and
they will willingly accept the
interference with their Liberty from the
government because they think they'll be
kept safe but but the the the value
theme not the history theme the value
theme is that each president relies on
the uncorrect 'add uninterruptible
relied on some of the things that FDR
did and george w bush did to justify
well let's talk about obama real quick
then because you know my he's helping me
sell the book Nick with what he's doing
with with immigration as we speak right
because III assume that you're in favor
of more open borders and more
immigration I am absolutely in favor of
open borders because of your natural
right to travel wherever you want to go
and right as I believed more immigrants
a rising tide lifts all ships that's
right not a popular view with the place
where I work during the day but I
believe that but you just you you can't
put up with the way that Obama is
trying to create immigration well when
President Obama says to five million
foreign nationals if you do ABC DNA you
won't be deported and he makes up the
ABC DNA and defies the laws written by
Congress laws that were there at the
time he took his first presidential oath
what is he doing he's disenfranchising
the American voters who elected Congress
to write the laws
he's superseding a co-equal branch of
the government by writing his own laws
if that is not impeachable territory
it's hard to imagine what would be he
has said that there's a balance to be
struck between liberty and security
every one of his predecessors has said
that except for Thomas Jefferson and and
this is my question is there a balance
to be struck no there is no balance to
be struck the relationship between
Liberty and and safety is bias a bias in
favor of Liberty Liberty is the default
position if our rights come from our
humanity as Jefferson wrote in the
Declaration of Independence if if the
source of our rights is our humanity
whether you believe we were created by
an all-knowing God or whether you think
we're just the highest and strongest
natural naturally existing creature on
the planet at the moment then the
government can't take our rights away by
a majority vote and if that is the case
then there is no balance between liberty
and Safety because when the government
wants safety and it needs my liberty it
must persuade me to give up my Liberty
you can't give up my Liberty I can't
give up yours the Congress can't give up
both of ours to put that in a historical
context was it right during World War
two a war that most you know everybody
agrees that we were in been involved in
was it right to have rationing was it
right to have the government temporarily
take over commandeer private resources
whether they were businesses well not
only was it not right it wasn't
constitutional the the half dozen cases
in which it was challenged the courts
ruled in favor of the government but but
which would you prefer ration goods the
government which will always give itself
what it needs first or the free market
which which when unregulated will engage
in a pure and nearly perfect rationing
supply and demand so you don't think
that the government during World War two
could say to private industry strive to
stop using rubber to do this we need it
for tires absolutely not the government
has to pay for it just like just like
everybody else and in fact if the
government had stayed out my parents
would have been able to buy shoe leather
and coffee and tea and sugar when they
were teenagers rather than having to
wait on line as if they were in the
Soviet Union you talked about natural
rights natural law where where our
rights come from the book starts early
on you mentioned st. Thomas More a big
fan of st. Thomas More and and explain
for those of us who have not seen a man
for all seasons or yeah read the play
working on to Catholic school when I was
an undergraduate all right when I was a
law student excuse me at the University
of Notre Dame before classes started my
first year I went into the bowels of the
library to find the transcript of the
trial of Sir Thomas More it was a
handwritten transcript I'm sure it was a
copy I don't know that it was an
original and I I read it and I also read
the the famous play on which the movie
has made Robert bull written by a
Protestant by the right and bull it was
absolutely faithful to the language and
and Thomas More just put it in context
he was the it was the right answer
essentially of correct for Henry the a
correct the charge was treason the the
under the horrific law at the time the
proven treason was his silence his
refusal to say affirmative ly that the
king is the head of the church on earth
so more is more made a mistake he
defended himself made a mistake a lawyer
who represents himself as a fool for a
client but as a practical matter the the
deck was stacked against him I mean he
could have had the Archangel Gabriel
they are defending him and he still
would have lost in the course of
defending himself he makes a great
defence of the natural law but arguing
to the jury the following this is
directly from the transcript which was
adopted in the play some men say the
earth is round and some men say it's
flat a legitimate area of dispute and
that time we're talking about 1535 but
if it is round could the king's command
flatten it and if it is flat could an
act of parliament make it
now of course the King under the 8th
can't flatten around earth and of course
Parliament couldn't make a flat earth
round so he was not only appealing to
the common sense of the jurors but to
their understanding of the natural law
of the order of things that even
governments are subject to from that he
proceeded to argue that among our
natural rights is freedom of thought and
the essential aspect of freedom of
thought as much as it is speech it is
silence lost the argument he lost his
head 400 years later unlike Paul the
sixth he had to wait for hundred years
another argument for another time dick
he he was he was canonized he's the
patron saint of lawyers you know you can
commit a lot of sins and still be a
saint if you embrace martyrdom at the
end even though his wife said M Thomas
you're not a martyr he goes you're right
this is not the stuff of which martyrdom
is made but if it comes we must embrace
it I use that a lot in my talks talk
about why is the natural law so
important to you and why should it why
should a concern people in 21st century
America well it's important to me
because it was important to the framers
and everyone of the framers under
understood the importance of the natural
law as a natural check on the government
what is it it's the area pointing to my
heart it's the area of human behavior
for which we don't need a government
permission slip and you can basically go
through the Bill of Rights your right to
think as you wish to say what you think
to publish what you say your right to
worship or not to worship to associate
or not to associate to petition the
government your right to shoot at the
government when it's taken over by
tyrants the quintessential American
right and the Fourth Amendment the right
to be left alone these are aspects of
our humanity they are not subject to
majoritarian impulses the majority can't
take them away John Locke a favorite
philosopher of Jefferson once said the
majority can no longer silence one
person for all the world but one thinks
something the whole world could not
morally silence that one any more than
he if he had the power could silence the
whole world
I've told Bill O'Reilly he should be
grateful
but but that's the essence of the
natural law that nobody can take your
rights away from you not the government
not a king you and your rights up if you
violate somebody else's natural rights
so one of the thief Rob's the bank he
gives up his own right to be free he
doesn't give up the rights of the bank
to be divested of its wealth he just
gives up his own right to be free
because he stole the money he stole
property that wasn't his let's talk
about the title of the book suicide pact
because this is you know it's a phrase
that everybody knows that the
Constitution is not a suicide the
explication of the case of the Supreme
Court case that comes out of this is
faster okay this also has to do with my
day job right where I work with a lot of
people who when I defend the primacy of
the individual and and our natural
rights say to me ah the Constitution is
not a suicide pact and I'd say where'd
you get that from whoa I got it from but
I know it makes sense the Constitution
somebody some judge said it during World
War two and the idea that it's not a
suicide pact is that you know is that is
that our rights are not absolute and the
government can curtail those rights in
bad times right and expand them in good
times
by the way that argument that the
government can curtail them in bed and
expand them and good is the opposite of
the natural law that's what's called
positivism that's what brought us Nazism
and communism and fascism when the
government can tinker with your rights
in order to strengthen itself so a very
famous case it's post-world War two its
1949 Chicago it's the Red Scare era it's
the Joe McCarthy era and a very famous
sort of radical Catholic priest by the
name of Arthur Tennant termina yellow
and let's say you're not sort of radical
he was out he was over the job he made
he made you and me Seymour is giving a
speech and his purpose is to arouse the
audience and the audience hates them
they are there to be aroused right so
the audience begins to storm the stage
and the Chicago Police say father term
in yellow you got to get out of here we
can't protect you he basically tells the
priest tells the the cops what they can
go do with themselves the audience
storms the stage destroys the building
and instead of arresting the audience
members who did the damage they arrest
father termen yellow
convicted in a Chicago trial court
upheld in a Chicago appellate court
upheld by the Chicago Oh by the allah
noi supreme court reversed by the u.s.
supreme court arguing that the First
Amendment value of the freedom of speech
is so broad so expansive it will
tolerate the violence of the listener
and by the way you guys in Chicago you
should have arrested the people that
stormed the stage because that's not
protected but speech is protective
Justice Robert Jackson who left the
Supreme Court to become the chief
American prosecutor at Nuremberg and
when the Nuremberg trials were over went
right back to his job in the Supreme
Court of a movement today that is
unthinkable but happened at the time
dissented and in the dissent used this
phrase the constitutional Bill of Rights
is not a suicide pact that dissent has
been is outdated has never been followed
and though I respect a lot of what
justice Jackson did he mentored a young
lawyer named Bill Rehnquist who
eventually became an admirable chief
justice the the phrase is meaningless I
use it all the time because the neo-cons
love it and when you get an argument
with a neocon about suicide pact read
the apologia in here and you'll blow
your neocon adversaries away you talk
about in the context of 20 21st century
presidential action Bush was the great
tragedy but Obama has become the great
hypocrite how how was Bush a tragic
figure in terms of the expansion and
abuse of presidential power well I'll
tell you I'll give you an anecdote and
then I'll talk big literature in the
Bush administration it became known that
FBI agents were showing up at post
offices and intimidating postal
inspectors a tonne of turnover the mail
a postal inspector is a cop in a uniform
of the badge and a gun whose job is to
ensure that the mail is not interfered
with an FBI agent is a cop not in a
uniform with a badge and a gun not
visible they intimidated the postal
agents a Republican Congress wrote a
piece of legislation and passed it
thou shalt not interfere with the mail
you want to open up the mail go to a
judge present probable cause get a
search warrant from a judge perfectly
with the 4th amendment as george w bush
was signing this piece of legislation
into law literally as the ink in the pen
and his fingers was flowing onto the
page he stopped and looked up to the
camera and said by the way I have no
intention whatsoever of enforcing this
law now that attitude that I can nullify
what the Congress has done magnify it to
today it's the same value of Barack
Obama who says you 5 million people that
I don't want to deport do my ABCD and E
and I won't deport you and how did Obama
do this well while he's doing it as we
speak
but one of the academic if you will
basis for it
was things like what Bush did because it
was uninterested
for doing nothing when when Barack Obama
bombed Libya while Congress was on
spring break remember that it's about
2009 2010 he literally sent American
bombs to destroy American military
equipment that American taxpayers had
paid for and given to Qaddafi cause
chaos Qaddafi was dead arguably the the
nonsense in Benghazi and the
assassination of our ambassador happens
as a result of this the Congress do
anything
nothing was it lawful no wasn't even
lawful under the War Powers Resolution
was a dubious constitutionality george w
bush of course brought us into an
unlawful war under false pretences he
tortured people he spied on people
Barack Obama's greatest sin in my view
is his belief that he can kill Americans
and his execution his murder of
Americans uncharged untried unprosecuted
unconvicted unsent
it would have been unlawful for the FBI
or the CIA to have kidnapped them and
brought them here because they weren't
even charged with a crime if they had
been indicted and they refused to show
up some law that allows the that allows
the kidnapping what's Barack Obama's
legal theory what had Eric Holder the
enablers say to him we're due process is
inconvenient the president can be judged
jury and executioner
Jefferson and Madison and William O
Douglas and everybody took a stand for
human liberty would be turning in their
graves do you think that this type of
action and I doubt that most of us you
know have it have it obviously have a
sharp an understanding of the legal kind
of pyrotechnics and gymnastics that are
going on here but when you start to see
authority figures and you know the
president is a stand-in for ultimate
authority right started fooling around
with stuff saying like I'm signing this
law but I'm not gonna follow it or Obama
coming in and saying you know what I'm
gonna stop doing everything George Bush
said except I'm actually gonna do more
of it and do it in more extreme ways
where I can even you know I have a
secret kill list what is the effect on
on the population what is the effect on
the American well when it's done during
wartime
and and let's face it Nick in your
lifetime in mine we have been in a state
of perpetual war perpetual war perpetual
debt and government control of human
liberty those are the three areas that
both political parties leadership agree
on but when it's done in wartime people
usually opt for safety over Liberty
people will pay more taxes and stand on
a ration line and do what the president
tells them so that's why george w bush
and barack obama are able to get away
with this because the public buys the
nonsense that this is going to keep them
safe by the same token you know you
point out in the book that when Bush
left office only a third of people
approved of the job he had done
two-thirds were against that Obama is
sinking in the poll and is I kind of a
trajectory to be out of office with
similar bad numbers does it ultimately
build up and and hollow out the you know
the concept of legitimate Authority and
is that is that a problem you know we're
also talking about this as the Eric
corner rather the the grand jury that
was supposed to look at the death of
Eric garner the NYPD does not return an
indictment just not not a guilty you
know a guilty sentence I'd rather just
know somebody you know what do what I
will find out what happened the one good
thing the one good thing that may come
from Bush's abuse of power and Obama's
taking it on steroids so to speak is
that the person who wrote the foreword
to this book is rising in the polls and
an interest and the interest is being
shown in
uniquely Unruh publican areas of the of
the populous inner-city blacks college
college youth Rand Paul wrote a very
very generous forward is really the only
type of person with that mentality who
would reverse this inexorable march
toward authoritarianism and such a
reversal would need to come on the heels
of a great abuse right the likes of
which we see today and I mean you do
have a sense you know we target reason a
lot about the libertarian moment you're
certainly part of it you're rising
profile a lot of the people at Fox who
are libertarian people like Rand Paul
Justin Amash libertarian Republicans
interest from the Democrats or from
liberals who are like you know what you
know we we got to change the way we're
doing things you know is you know is it
possible that that's what is going to
rise out of the ashes well I I think it
is and I'll give you an example you
talked about the Eric garner tragedy in
in New York City one of the people
making the most out of this tragedy is
one of my colleagues in the media though
not at Fox the Reverend Al Sharpton mhm
two weeks ago out Sharpton had breakfast
with Rand Paul and at the end of the
breakfast he told his colleagues at
MSNBC this is the most dangerous man
running for the Democrats why because we
will not be able to count on the votes
of inner-city blacks the way we used to
many of them may vote for him that is
one of the most startling revelations
that can come from Obama's excess and
just to follow up with Rand Paul in his
intro and his foreword to the book which
is great as is the whole book he writes
that the biggest question is whether a
judge's warrant kind of the questions
you raise here the biggest question is
whether a judge's warrant is needed for
a search of third-party information well
you see the Patriot Act truly one of the
most abominable and unconstitutional
pieces of legislation since the Alien
and Sedition Act allows federal agents
to search third parties by third parties
it would be somebody who has records on
your lawful records on you your
telephone company or a computer server
your doctor your lawyer your supermarket
FBI agents can write their own search
warrants and serve them on the third
party and when they serve them on the
third party they say to that third party
you can't tell anybody about this you
can't tell your spouse in the bedroom
your lawyer and her office of priests
and confessional you can't even tell a
judge in a public courtroom because if
you tell somebody will prosecute you for
speech all of that is in the Patriot Act
and Rand Paul rails against it and you
know people like Edward snowed are the
revelations that came out of various
things from WikiLeaks and Edward Snowden
these you know these broadened our
understanding of how much surveillance
and how much kind of creepy-crawly is
going on you know where a single search
warrant somehow or a single law is used
as the pretext to search millions if not
billions of records or you know how do
how do we push back against that I mean
beyond well we need to push back against
it either by having a president who
could stop it with the stroke of a pen
or a phone call or by scaring members of
Congress out that they're gonna lose
their jobs they're gonna be voted out of
office if they permit this to continue
one of the things that affected Congress
the most was when it writ when it
realized that it was being spied on by
the executive branch that to arguably
violates the separation of powers who
runs the NSA the president president
people are spying on Congress what
member of Congress would tolerate that
when they can stop it with a simple
majority vote you also teach first-year
law at Brooklyn Law School you teach
constitutional law and and other
introductory courses do you have a cent
are you are you confident that the
lawyers in training now will be fierce
defenders of the know III teach the
basic course in the Constitution which
is basically two hundred famous Supreme
Court cases that all lawyers need to
know in order to pass the bar exam I
also teach an advanced course on legal
philosophy non theories of interpreting
the Constitution I taught these things
at Seton Hall Law School in Newark 20
years ago today and these law schools
are roughly about the same they draw
roughly from the same socio-economic
demographic they they are roughly ranked
the same and nationally and they're both
the inner city I see a far more
passionate grasp of civil liberties
today than I did 20 years ago well in
fact the comparison is not even close
I'm kind of sorry to hear
that because people are kind of
intensified on these or have lit on
these issues because they're they're
being abused yeah of course they're
being abused look one of my dear friends
in the media is the one of the funniest
guys in the world Jon Stewart first time
I'm on there with him I said to him hey
Jon I'm gonna out you tonight whatever
you can out be I'm gonna out you as a
closeted libertarian I went through a
half-dozen issues yes I agree yes I
agree yes I agree yes I agree oh my god
I can't go home tonight I'm a
libertarian well we will leave it there
we've been talking with Judge Andrew P
Napolitano he's on Fox News all the time
and he's the author of the tremendous
new book suicide pact the radical
expansion of presidential powers and the
assault on civil liberties judge thanks
am I thank you thanks Nick all the best
for recent TV I'm Nicolas new